[Música]
que quieren cambiar al mundo
por qué
cambiar es evolucionar y la naturaleza
del humano
es evolucionar
yo lo divido en tres cosas
sueños
amor
y convicción
la convicción la voy a explicar a su
debido tiempo sueños
desde niño tus sueños y cuando sueñas
lo primero que piensas es que va a decir
la gente de mí
y entonces te haces para atrás y ves la
pregunta enorme
qué van a decir de lo que estoy diciendo
de lo que estoy soñando y de lo que
realmente me hace sentir vivo y eso es
lo primero que destruye los sueños
lo que va a decir la gente
es lo que me importa a mí y entonces
empiezo a soñar ya logramos soñar
estamos felices porque estamos soñando
despiertos y dormidos
ahora tenemos que movernos del lugar
para que ese sueño se logre como una
cosa de principio básico y entonces ahí
es cuando te cuestionas
tengo convicción para mi sueño
y ahí es cuando tienes que elegir un
camino y no importa el camino que elijas
y qué tan largo sea
voy a poner un ejemplo
yo estaba estudiando otra cosa y un día
había una película
y cuando vi esa película dije yo quiero
cambiar el mundo
porque porque eso es lo que recalcaba la
película quiero cambiar este mundo
volvió a ver la escena y dije tengo que
ser actor y ahí viene mi convicción el
camino iba a ser muy largo porque yo
estaba en otro lugar y no importará no
importaba todo lo que iba a ser el
camino era muy muy largo y entonces me
acuerdo de una historia que me contaron
que decía
la calle es muy larga y yo soy un
barrendero
si yo volteo hacia el futuro y veo lo
larga que es la calle me va a costar
mucho trabajo barrer la y entonces mejor
barro un pedacito y bailo
y vuelvo a barrer otro pedacito y bailo
y cuando vuelvo a ver la calle la veo
que está enorme y que ya la cabe y veo
un pasado enorme que ya lo hice entonces
fue cuando me volvía a preguntar qué era
lo que tenía que hacer cambiar el mundo
y entonces es cuando decido volver a ver
esta peli y vamos a verla juntos
al fuego
tú qué haces aquí que sí qué haces aquí
en la escuela
aquí ha venido
yo
a estudiar
estoy en el qué
interpretación por qué
como qué por qué por qué teatro alguna
razón tendrá no
pues he elegido esto como podrías haber
elegido informática no porque esto es lo
que me gusta
el que te gusta pues el teatro me gusta
el teatro ya
y dime
para que cree que sirve toda esta
historia del teatro
a veces creo que para mucho y otras que
para nada la verdad pero tú piensas que
debería servir para algo no sí
por lo menos para mejorar
y sean más conscientes nosotros mismos
no se nos quieren mejorar una
muchos oído
esto no quiere mejorar una
a ti te preocupan otro tipo de cosas
eso es lo que te pasó a ti
se puede saber de todo esto ahora
el otro día me falta hasta el respeto
a mí
y a todos los demás
mintiéndonos a todos contándonos esa
película sobre tu vida mira
aquí no somos tus marionetas de aquí la
gente se deja el pellejo
saca a relucir cosas muy jodidas de su
vida pero muy jodida
se mojan
pero tú no
y encima pretendes cachón cierto de
nosotros
no tiene el respeto por nada ni por
nadie
bájate
eso es cierto
al no es cierto
qué es lo que no es cierto yo no quería
casarme de nadie pues yo pienso que sí
mira que ha venido a eso solamente yo le
digo que no y entonces aquí ha venido me
quieres decir
no sé contestar o no sabe porque quiero
hacer teatro realmente tengo muchísimo
interés en saber porque ha venido aquí
[Música]
quiero hacer teatro porque quiero hacer
algo por mí por los demás
[Música]
quiero hacer teatro porque creo que
sirve para comunicarse entre los seres
humanos porque creo que puede ser un
camino hacia el entendimiento y hacia la
comprensión
por eso
[Música]
si quieres también
me encantaría cambiar este mundo
y creo que todavía se está contando
[Música]
sucede que óscar janeada que es el
personal el actor que estás en ese
personaje en una película que se llama
noviembre es una película española que
habla sobre un grupo de teatro y óscar
jaenada se sube al escenario después de
haber hecho una burla en su grupo de
teatro y el profesor le cuestiona que
por qué decide ser actor y él se sube y
dice que porque quiere cambiar este
mundo y que él respeta tanto el teatro
porque encontró una manera de
comunicarse una manera de decir lo que
pensaba
y entonces cuando la volví a ver después
de haber decidido tomar la decisión de
mi vida y de tener una convicción
encontré mi vocación que era contar
historias y eso era de la manera que
quería decir las cosas y entonces ya no
entendí que la palabra más importante de
esa escena era cambiar este mundo
entendí que la palabra o la frase más
importante de esa escena era el teatro
como modo de comunicación y entonces
entendí que en mi vocación y lo que me
hace sentir vivo todos los días es
contar una historia
y a eso viene la tercera que es hacer
las cosas con amor
voy a poner un claro ejemplo de por qué
creo yo que las cosas se hacen con amor
todas aquí hemos visto la película
titanic no
ok entonces en la película titanic que
es como realmente lo que está pasando
ahorita en la sociedad en algún punto se
va a hundir el barco no y es como si
estuviéramos a punto de enfrentar el
coronavirus y todos estuviéramos
contagiados y entonces están a punto de
hundirse en el barco y resulta que tres
personas que creen en sus sueños que
tienen una convicción o que tienen amor
por lo que hacen deciden empezar a tocar
música que la música es amor propio y
entonces tú dices ay qué bonito no
entonces van a lo que está haciendo es
lo está distrayendo está amenazando su
muerte no lo que se está haciendo es
darle la oportunidad de que vean de otra
perspectiva lo que están viviendo en ese
momento y entonces es cuando yo entendí
que las cosas y justo se hacen con amor
y cambian y modifican las cosas y
entonces vuelvo a mi resumen
cómo puedo cambiar el mundo
soñando
soñé que quería ser actor y ahora lo soy
porque ya soy actor según
con convicción con vocación
y así el mundo no tenga un teatro donde
actuar yo voy a tratar de salir a contar
una historia porque eso es lo que me
hace sentir vivo
y la tercera es que lo hago con amor
cuando encuentro estas 3 herramientas
para querer modificar y cambiar el mundo
a mi manera
encuentro algo sumamente valioso
no se trata de que piense y programe
para soñar 365 días o para hacer las
cosas 365 días
lo hago específicamente
para pensar en un día
y cuando estoy justo en ese día pienso
que debería de pensar en un minuto
y cuando estoy en ese minuto pienso que
debería pensar en justo en este segundo
y justo este segundo es el único que
tengo para sonreír y para creer en mis
sueños para tener mi vocación y para
cambiar el mundo la verdad es que esta
conciencia yo creo que se la puedo pasar
a alguien más y ese alguien más le puede
pasar a alguien más y si todos creemos
en nuestros sueños hacemos lo que nos
gusta y realmente lo hacemos con amor
vamos a cambiar este mundo y creo que
ese es mi sueño cambiarlo modificarlo
porque eso nos va a hacer evolucionar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
e